after all these days telling air is law
stop wearing a blue shirt if I have a
blue screen I ruin my own word are the
lights in my glasses upsetting you trust
me they have set me even more hey rock
stars I know I'm not Erik Bosse
obviously I'm Way too handsome I'm
actually Eriksen no relation I'm the
lead editor here in new rock stars Erik
is actually out of the office
for a vacation leaving me here all alone
to wake up and find and don't swim just
drop the brand new trailer for Rick and
Morty season 3 along with a release date
of July 30th which means I'm going to
have to start paying for my cable be
reconnect on the 29th and yeah Eric's
not here and I have barely washed up but
I've watched a trailer a dozen times
there's so much I noticed about possible
storylines and references that I just
figured why should you guys wait till
eric gets back I'll just give it a whirl
and give you my own breakdown on the
Rick and Morty season 3 trailer what's
the worst that could happen I'll even do
a sponsor at four quid that free app
that lets you collect and trade stickers
you can paste over your text messages to
add that extra amount of character to
your interactions after all we do have a
bunch of Rick and Morty stickers you
can't find anywhere else and you notice
I'm mentioning them and they loved it so
much last time I think I'll have another
one is contact where to you win a Rick
and Morty Funko pop anyway let's talk
about Rick and Morty season three oh and
I guess I should say spoiler I'm going
to be talking a lot about what may or
may not happen in this upcoming season
and you guys seem to really hate it when
we're right and let's just get into it
shall we
okay so I'm going to skip over the
obvious clips from the first episode of
the seasons we already cover the entire
episode to break down that I edited so
superbly so you can go check that out
when you have a chance instead I want to
focus on the new footage mystery which
parodies many familiar sci-fi and
fantasy properties that we all know and
love and try to predict some of the
satirical stories they might have
planned let's start off with a pickle
Rick which for fans should be a familiar
image we saw a short animatic on this
episode of Comic Con last year which we
see part of again here in a more
finished form and it looks fantastic
we wanted to see how Rick escapes this
sceptic he'll hold as he explodes out of
a toilet wearing a makeshift gas mask
may I have a rats head later it seems he
finds while being chased by some armed
agent type goon and he later gets a drop
on them by messaging an explosive code
it sets off an assay me huge bomb hidden
under the desk there staring at and I'm
guessing this might be a reference to
Independence Day making fun of the
ridiculous idea of the
send a computer virus to aliens also was
a pretty complex bomb to have just built
when you're the size of a shrimp love
cucumber so I'm wondering is this
another one of Ric circuitous plan also
how did he end up in the sewer and if
this is in his plan why was he so
excited to be a pickle I mean between
having to construct an entire Rube
Goldberg iron rat suit device with your
tongue and be chased by firearm wielding
ruffians I don't imagine Ric is enjoying
himself all that much I don't know you
let me know what you think
okay the next storyline I noticed seems
to be a mixture of Avatar and
tomorrowland as Rick flies a Jerry and a
ship towards the biodome city in the
middle of this Pandora like planting
naturally seemed to take a turn for the
worst as Rick and Jerry find themselves
in a roller coaster ride that had two
unfriendly looking aliens trying to kill
Rick behind them the miserable moment
but you look closely in this shot you
can see one of them holding a rifle at
Rick's head horse things get worse when
the roller coaster crashes outside the
park and Jerry finds himself alone in
the path of this alien beast reminiscent
of a moment from Avatar when jakesully
runs into a similar situation now
there's another very missable thing here
I've heard some people notice and it's
this hole in the middle of Rick's shirt
some people think this has to be a
connection to an Iron Man like scenario
but I'm pretty sure that's blood
surrounding that hole so it almost seems
like at some point Rick got shot and
either with a wound healed or maybe he
was wearing some sort of protective
layer underneath either way it connects
to another clue as to what might be
happening this episode as we later see
the same Rick with the same hole in his
shirt revealed himself to be a robot
with a transformer like laser on so I'm
thinking this wasn't even our original
c-137 Rick after all this first episode
of season we see Rick get Jerry kicked
out of the house and seemed very happy
about it
so which Rick is this and actually is
this our original Jerry after all we saw
more unite run there are various Jerry's
that's all the Rick's are aware of let's
move on next episode this is clearly a
Mad Max omage start to finish we have
the motorcade there's the moral July
character being killed by summer and a
very OSA role using a shotgun set looks
madly similar to Max's at first I
thought this might be in the Cronenberg
world as I tried definitely figure out
what they were cooking on that skewer
but then I remembered that the serum
Rick made a Rick potion number 9 only
affects people that are not related to
Maury and
so unless everyone in this shot is
related I think it's safe to assume that
this is a place we haven't visited yet
also if you look closely at Rick at the
from the motorcade you'll notice this
gun is holding is the same gun he is
holding when he mauryans summer-fall I'm
a Portland rod as if they just narrowly
missed some sort of dark demise so I'm
thinking things are going to work out
from this time around but what I'm
really curious about is what is this
green glowing object next to Rick in the
passenger seat I don't see Morty
anywhere but I also don't think that
this is him more likely it's something
that Rick's going to use either to save
Morty or trade for Maurice life or it
might just be a totally different
character entirely moving on to another
episode we get a very brief glimpse of
as The Vindicator of guardians of
galaxy's last Avengers like group of
superheroes that seem to role Marty as
part of the Bruce it gets quilted
insignia on Morty jacket it matches the
same insignia on Chris Pratt's looking
character and the insignia on the base
the pulsating purple gem that seemed
Achatz to Rick when they need him
gems cosmic superheroes a hellish
landscape with a giant overlord I think
this is going to be a very heavy parody
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe oh and
I've got another episode I noticed but
first I got to play about quick okay so
first off thank you to quit for
sponsoring today's video your faith in
me is only matched by the death of your
sticker collection which is massive and
only rivaled by your ability to allow
quit use to collect cars and 3d figures
all conveniently on their phones so it
never leaves them basically takes me
back to the elementary school days I
used to have my own personal sticker
collection that I would share and train
with my fellow classmates back then I
only had ponies and dolphins not Rick
and Morty or venture time or oh my god
yes they even had screen clean any of
what I've heard they're always adding
more stickers to their collection for
you to drag and drop into your text
messages like Kendrick Lamar dropped mad
bars on dope beats sure that's the first
time that's ever been said on this
channel and before you even save
yourself oh yeah maybe I'll download it
like a week from now these stickers do
run out and can be super rare so good
luck or else you're going to have to
find someone to trade with but did I
mention there are new rock star stickers
arrows circles and our famous lightning
bolts I'm only asking cuz I'm looking
for someone to trade with all right if
you like Funko pops they have those too
oh and speaking of Funko pops can you
follow new rock stars on Twitter and
share this video with the hashtag pickle
Rick stars
you could be one of two people to win a
Rick and Morty Funko pop and then if you
want to you can search out the other
person one and get
married no pressure is you just do what
you want with your life anyway that's
enough of that back to the video right
now there was one last storyline I was
able to hone in on but before I talk
about that let me just acknowledge the
scenes I couldn't connect anything
there's a shot of mortium bass blowing
up summer decide the Iron Giant which
ends up being a double reference to
honey I blew up the kid and the 50-foot
woman and it's also followed by the
introduction of a new character Jean who
is obviously inspired by Wilson's a
friendly neighbor from one of my
favorite shows of the 90s kid home
improvement you also see an emotionless
mourning with an arm the size of the
Hulk choking out this poor guy in a
bathtub before being interrupted by Rick
mixing potions or possibly alcohol in
the corner now this could be a game of
Thrones style episode but people have
also brought up the Witcher and I'm apt
to agree because both Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland have spoken very
following that video game series there
is this quick scene of Rick and Morty
tied to a giant piano device the most
Adam West's Batman scenario I've ever
seen I mean look how deliciously camp
this all is there's a giant piano with
an even smaller piano on top of it and
I'm willing to bet a lunch that that
piano is directly connected the Hammers
above our heroes head there's a part of
me that thinks this could also be
connected of indicators episode because
the color scheme of this place matches
the scene I mentioned earlier but these
dead characters all look exactly the
same and Morty isn't wearing a
Vindicator jacket but then again this
could be moments before the Vindicator
is come in and save the two of them and
there's a final shot of summer with a
more beefed up cyber version of herself
getting ready to possibly murder Rick I
don't know this whole shot leaves a lot
the imagination some people have even
guessed this might be the original
summer from Cronenberg world but I think
it's kind of lucky considering how much
she and her parents were against Rick's
technology in Wrath that's us no but
then again maybe she's decided to
embrace this evil to destroy the evil
that created it I don't know I'm not an
expert of this stuff after all I'm
literally just guessing off of like 30
frames of footage
okay so there's another episode I've
been skirting around and it's possibly
the most interesting storyline that's
been revealed and that's involving the
Melton morning Rick now throughout the
entire trailer there's these two green
boogie men their scene battling Rick and
Morty in the normal world leaving us to
believe that these are the villains of
this episode but this final scene turns
everything upside down as we realize
that Rick and Morty seemingly covered in
the goo they're standing in their faces
melting or trying to escape this putrid
melty face hell by the way there are a
lot of health escapes
this trailer desert sewer a literal hell
and now this green snot rod location
Rick was not kidding when they said this
is going to their darkest year ever
anyway I get off track people seem to
think that this location is also the
fronton bird world I beg to differ
because the aliens we see all look like
they originated from different species
and all the surroundings seem more like
the creatures have melted rather than
transform still wherever this is Rick
and Morty seem to have been put here by
someone and then other theories of these
two non-green Rick and Morty's could be
the evil Rick and Morty from season one
closer counters are at times now rented
that Rick was a robot but we never did
see where the more that was controlling
him wet this could be him and this Rick
could be a robot Rick or this could also
just be a regular Rick and Morty so
desperate to find a safe place to call
their own one of those interesting
things about this show has always been
the immorality of a lot of Rick's
decision yes you're some of the
virtually meter jerks but most of them
are just like Rick jerks but but you
know lovable jerks
since the first season I've always
wondered what happy started following
another pair of a good Morty
sometimes I wasn't even sure we were
still following the same one and this
could be that story so what do you think
they are
is this a Cronenberg world and are these
are original Rick and Morty or these
just another pair of ragam or he's
trying to survive let me know what you
think in these comments or just tweet me
it's just Eric's also if you haven't yet
follow us the new rock star it gets
close to winning Funko pop doll but it
also have to keep up the day with all
our videos that were coming out with and
we have a lot coming out including some
big changes you're going to want to hear
about oh and if you want to be a part of
the changes you can become a member of
our patron family just $1 gets you
behind the scenes news and articles that
we don't offer anywhere else I guess
I'll leave you with a love peace and
chicken grease that's all I got okay I'm
doing it